[Musique]
chaque jour ces femmes seront dans ce
bidonville au sud de new day défiant la
canicule elles visitent des dizaines
d'habitations
en inde impossible de parler santé sans
parler d'elle elles sont connues sous le
nom de travailleuses achats achats
signifie espoir en hindi elles sont plus
d'un million dans le pays leur rôle
veiller quotidiennement sur la santé des
habitants dans les quartiers les plus
pauvres
ce quartier nous a été assignée nous
suivons environ 400 maisons ça
représente 2000 habitants et nous
prenons soin de chacun qu'il s'agisse de
femmes enceintes ou de personnes âgées
c'est comme une enquête de voisinage que
nous réalisons tous les jours
ni médecin ni infirmière ces
travailleuses médico social sont souvent
les premières interlocutrice des
communautés marginalisées
à l'origine ce programme né en 2006
visait à pallier les déserts médicaux
dans les zones rurales notamment pour
convaincre les futures mères d'accoucher
à l'hôpital plutôt que chez elle et
diminuer ainsi la mortalité infantile et
maternelle
le tout en se reposant sur un réseau de
femmes directement issus des villages où
elles suivent une série d'ateliers de
formation
parmi les problèmes récurrents nous
pouvons citer les femmes enceintes qui
n'ont pas accès à un suivi régulier de
leur grossesse ou encore les nouveaux
nés qui souffre de fièvre et de diarrhée
car le premier hôpital se situe très
loin de ces familles l'idée du programme
achat était donc de former des femmes
aux premiers soins et de permettre à ces
populations de se raccrocher au système
de santé
car l'inde rurale manque cruellement de
docteur les campagnes compte pour 65
portion de la population mais ne
bénéficie que de 30 % du personnel
soignant du pays bien souvent dans des
cliniques privées hors de prix pour la
majorité de la population
pire deux médecins sur trois en inde
aurait mis les diplômes ni les
qualifications requises pour exercer un
chiffre qui grimpe en des zones urbaines
à 1500 km à l'est de la capitale
indienne l'état de l'orissa est l'un des
plus pauvres du pays
matilda koulou est une travailleuse
achats depuis 16 ans elle fut l'une des
premières en inde à la en charge près de
1000 familles dans un rayon de 5 km un
énorme travail de porte-à-porte elle
doit veiller à ce que les personnes
malades suis bien leur traitement c'est
le cas de cet homme atteint de l'ebre
montrez-moi le pied arrêtés de gonfler
on m'a dit prends des médicaments
pendant un an
oui tous les jours pendant un an et
surtout ne manquez pas une seule prise
c'est son premier mois de traitement il
va déjà mieux je surveille sa prise de
médicaments car il faut qu'ils
comprennent que s'ils ne la respecte pas
je dois ci lui rappeler qu'il ne doit
pas boire d'alcool sinon le traitement
ne fonctionnera pas
éduqué changer les mauvaises habitudes
mathilde a dû se battre au quotidien
contrôlé préjugés et les superstitions
locale
j'ai réalisé que beaucoup de personnes
ne connaissent les bénéfices de
l'hôpital il voulait uniquement être
soigné à la maison mais désormais toutes
les femmes du village se rendent en
clinique pour accoucher par exemple
auparavant de nombreux patients
s'automédiquer mentait sur la base de on
dit ça aussi ça a changé ils vont voir
un médecin puis à chaque le bon
traitement
le truc problèmes auxquels sont
confrontés les travailleuses à chasser
le rapport aux castes et elles doivent
toujours prendre cela en compte
certaines personnes leur dise ne soit
pas à côté de moi si elles sont issues
d'une caste inférieure à la leur
au fil des années les missions confiées
aux travailleuses de l'espoir se sont
multipliées planning familial lutte
contre la polio et la tuberculose
campagne de vaccination plus récemment
elle se sont retrouvés en première ligne
pendant la pandémie nous allons conduire
un programme de vaccination à domicile
donc soyez présents quand vont nous
prendre notre dose de rappel après neuf
mois exactement neuf mois après la
deuxième dose
mais désormais c'est sur un autre front
que se bat mathilde à et des dizaines de
milliers de travailleuses sociales
depuis plusieurs mois à travers le pays
elles multiplient les grèves et les
manifestations pour exiger une
requalification de leur statut
car aux yeux de l'état indien les
travailleuses achats sont des bénévoles
elles ne reçoivent qu'une faible
indemnité ne sont pas considérés comme
faisant partie du corps médical
selon les régions elle gagne à peine
entre 40 et 100 euros par mois un revenu
bien maigre pour celles qui risquent
leur vie pour sauver celle des autres
pendant la pandémie notre travail a été
salué le gouvernement a dit que nous
avions fait un travail remarquable
les gens nous applaudissaient on nous
offrait des fleurs en guise de
récompense mais ce n'est pas du tout
suffisant nous avons toute une famille à
nourrir nous voulons avoir droit à un
salaire minimum nous voulons être
reconnus comme de véritables aides
soignantes nous voulons bénéficier d'une
sécurité sociale et d'une retraite
leur dévouement a été récompensé par l'
oms qui leur a décerné le prix des
leaders de la santé mondiale un début de
reconnaissance pour celles qui sont
devenus les anges gardiennes de dizaines
de millions de démunis